[rock music]
- My name's Michael Peterson.
Welcome to my shop.
♪ ♪
I'm 33 years old.
I've been making knives
for about 22, 23 years.
This is my dad's
original shop
that he first started in
35 years ago.
♪ ♪
When I started showing interest
in making knives,
my dad encouraged me
quite a bit,
you know,
to spend more time out--
just get out there,
and just grind.
Grab a piece of metal,
and grind it into a blade.
Doesn't matter
if you screw it up.
The bigger the scrap pile,
the better you're gonna get
eventually.
♪ ♪
[upbeat rock music]
- So here we are Desloge--
beautiful Desloge, Missouri.
Hawthorne Forge.
Let me show you guys around
a little bit.
♪ ♪
This anvil was manufactured
in 1981.
Both of my grandpas,
it--it used to be
where they used to work,
back in the day
at a--at a factory.
My Grandpa Wigger, he was
the head of maintenance there.
So he actually used this anvil.
He actually gave this
to me, um,
so, I mean, this is a real
important, uh, anvil to me.
♪ ♪
- Again, this is a shop
that my dad put together.
Over here,
I got a 25-pound hammer
that I got from my folks,
and over here,
you can see I got
a selection of tongs
and my forge.
Right here, I got an old anvil
that my dad gave me
that was one of his original
ones he started with.
A lot of knives have been
forged out on this old girl
before he got his bigger ones.
There's a lot of history
of making knives here,
especially having this shop.
It's nothing super fancy
in here,
but I--what I got here
works for the job.
♪ ♪
- It was my goal to build
my own motorcycle.
This is my first real
blacksmith job.
It was when I first started
really getting into detail,
and I was getting a little bit
better at blacksmithing.
So this bike, I pretty much
built around the motor.
Did the hardtail, then I put--
made a sissy bar for it,
did all the turns
and the--and the scrolls on it.
Did all the linkages,
the shifting linkage
and the, you know--
I went all the way down
in braiding the wires
for the gussets.
I fancied those up,
and then I made the seat.
I actually took
a piece of metal,
and I screwed it
to a telephone pole,
and I beat it
around the telephone pole
to get that shape there,
and then I just took,
like, carpet padding,
put it on the seat, and then
I wrapped it in leather,
and then I did
the--the lacing here,
the stitching on the edge.
This is a big project,
a real big process for us.
I mean, I'm happy it's done.
I can say I'll probably
never do another one.
It was a lot of work, but
I--I really enjoyed doing it,
and this is something I'm gonna
hold onto and just cherish.
I mean, I hope you guys
enjoy it.